[Music]
have you have we all seen street
performers yeah I like that they do and
like you know anyone who performs on a
street yeah anyone that performs the
street die do you guys give money to
street performers sometimes leave they
make me feel good I actually follow one
that's really good I don't know how to
pronounce his name
I saw this leaf crook something yeah
he's a French guy and he dances to
Michael Jackson mostly any [ __ ] Will
Smith proposed to yeah does he dress
like Michael no he just wears normal
[ __ ] dress like like this was doing
moon walks on cobblestones and [ __ ] and
it's still smooth nice cast must be like
yeah yeah yeah insane control well what
what makes you guys want to pay I guess
I like offer money if they make me feel
good they move you right if they made me
if they made me stop and watch yeah and
then they come around or if I have extra
money in my pocket cuz I feel good like
cuz I made it or if they're missing legs
Oh true like it's more of a pity King
I'm like hopefully could buy some lates
maybe etic my dear ones Oh true what
about if I said would you pay this guy
if I asked you about this guy Rick it
looks like he has money he looks like he
hasn't what does he do
is he the robot guy you know like the
guys that are all you silver they start
doing the the robot thing or they just
stay still and then they scare you true
that that's I have seen that before too
what yeah what do you guys think that
that that's what this guy does I would
go punch her in the stomach I'll see how
hard is this amount of metal metal are
you a metal man I don't know if I would
just based off of looks not knowing what
he does I probably would it what is that
a boot that's like silver to like yeah
usually the silver ain't the silver guys
I don't tip them I've seen that genre
they usually just stay there yeah is
this guy
bad at it is he like kind of like moving
around his shoes I would think is bad
looks sad so this guy is in Indonesia
and it's not just Tim there's a whole
bunch of hims there's these guys there's
this guy I like he's buddy but there's a
silver surfer Silver Surfer yeah the
surfers now the problem with these guys
they okay they're called the silver men
the term is in Indonesian they call it
bigoted so Superman Usha manushya silver
that's lucious and the name that they're
being called now and their special
ability begging you blue all they're
doing they're painting themselves and
then they're just asking for money
they're not standing still and go ahead
and then give me money they're just
walking her up down the streets one give
me money give me money it does grab
attention though because they're so
silver exactly which has prompted a kind
of like a phenomenon now in in in
Indonesia we're all beggars now are
donning the silver this is the other
ones off like man that's my idea yeah I
over J I'm the og of this [ __ ] but
doesn't the cost of operation go up
that's what I was gonna say when you
just beg a normal clothes you're the
overheads pretty low but if you gotta
put on silver every time you pay for
that [ __ ] and then washing it out is
that you Tasha I think this is spray
paint - oh they're doing rub it on
because it dries faster we don't get any
toxins and [ __ ] just get house not even
organic bro they're all like naked or
not wearing shirts but that's nothing
more females no saying like in terms of
like say you're trying to save on money
you would paint the clothes you don't
have to do down much work Snowbird I
don't know his pants are pretty silver
well then the other people are white so
yes like so you're bringing back the
photos so this guy did it right I guess
where he painted himself and win the
clothes but these guys kind of gave up
on the heaves were enemies being
responsible they're partially painted it
dude
what but they look like mannequins but
the face part [ __ ] scares me because
it's like right next to them
how they get on there like how can i
cool those - that's true they look like
people you look scary he does cuz his
eyes are all dark
yes belly button freaks me a little
tubby but yeah so then now these are all
adults
this is spray paint like real [ __ ]
spray paint there's a video clip there I
saw one of them like spray paint you get
high from just applying it then so I
don't know it's a lot help I don't think
they're thinking that they're thinking
like how many dollars can I make today
exactly yeah so they're not even
thinking about the health if it's also
like men we also get to get high this
[ __ ] went viral when this video surfaced
oh no they sprayed a baby come on baby
it is kind of cute what it is
it is if you just imagine that they were
begging for money and they weren't
getting spray-painting well it's not
about the begging for money because
there's kids everywhere that are doing
that yeah yeah I mean that's the other
thing that they need money I'm just like
yeah like that's coming that could kill
the kid
yeah and that baby's perspective those
bug this is superpowers I don't know
what you would think as again but yeah
man like that's kind of like the
phenomenon right now in Indonesia is
that a lot of beggars are turning to you
know the painting themselves to kind of
get more attention so they could get
more money and they're bringing they're
bringing their entire families in so
there's like whole families of just like
children all painted in silver and
they're just on the side eating food and
you got your clips where I can see the
kids eating and then like there's sit
over eat it's like rubbing off you know
that I'm like are you eating it then
like it eventually rubs off so I want
enough like one guy comes out all goals
and everyone's like like why do we do
that first Wow
silver what if all poor people become
silver in Indonesian it's like crazy
like it becomes their thing you know
yeah maybe it's like cooler also because
their reflects more of a cool man in the
middle no I mean that you could say by
anything you could say that in a boxer
was I'm gonna for actually we're like
you know when you like you put a little
pull on a fire and you take it off you
can immediately grab it it's gonna be
hot but you can't it is it's gonna be
hot
no dissipate heat supervise I think it's
because also super thin
that's why oh you talk about the foil
you can grab it not the meat okay let me
touch the [ __ ] hot potato like when
you put a potato inside of a foil and
then you put in a fire
Joe learning locks in that game as a kid
hot potato he's like I can't I can't
touch it don't touch it oh these guys
are ripped though I love this the paint
way it's right there not read that guy's
rip rip they're begging for money cuz he
probably don't have food bro please
they're only ripped because they're like
malnourished
nobody is ripped like he's got a six
six-pack like the other guy was like
kind of fat but you could see like the
striations
I was wondering like what if my builders
adopted it is they already tan like
crazy yeah that sound like the same
concept right kind of accentuate huh
another metal yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
it always blows my mind though because I
think alright when you're like living in
the States we do have poverty but the
level of poverty that we have it's not
the same mm-hmm or if it is it's not out
in the open it's like there's like poor
areas in the different parts of the
country and then there's like pockets of
that but then like people won't see it
in a major city
well like you'll see homeless people
right and that's true but it's rare that
you see like homeless babies on the
street but at least like a lot of our
homeless they still know how to read
because they can write a sign but you
know please give me food but there's
people out there that education stopped
in like doing great yeah they don't know
how to write cannot read yes and I think
turning to this is gonna be better I
mean I guess it is if that's what
they're all doing damn I don't know yeah
that mean they're desperate also here we
have like child services and stuff so if
there was like a homeless I mean I'm
pretty sure they would take the kids
yeah they get priority yeah they'll
leave the parents though what so they
can get back on their feet like they
don't just take them forever like they
put the parents through programs and if
they pass it then they're like okay
you're a fit parent now well I mean it's
good that they do at least take the kids
so the kids can grow better than being
outside I know like these areas sound
tough cuz at least here like we have
programs of like where we could feed we
could house we can do a lot of different
things but here I don't know like in
Mexico - I don't think they have the
same thing you think any of them are
gonna start adopting the robot-man stuff
that we do in America and they're gonna
start making more money one starts doing
the paint people might have to start
implementing skills like you think like
they're making less money because like
they're standing still while everyone
else is running up to the car isn't it
like give me the money instead
[ __ ] I'm stuck wait I can't
you gotta keep coming up with new stuff
so imagine from there now it's like guys
that come out with a bird costume like
they just all feathers or like I'm you
know some guys are great like you know
how in Halloween if you wanted to
achieve costumes someone was always a
grape cuz they just no coast is it cheap
cause that's expensive you know no like
they just get purple balloons and then
they [ __ ] so they clothespin that
[ __ ] all over the kid's body and it put
like a green hat on one degree by a
cluster of grapes
what about size becoming like like Times
Square you know how like everybody's in
a costume I'll get money take a picture
Hollywood Boulevard
yeah like that yeah but we baby that we
pay them for their cool costumes right
but some of them are really bad they're
all that all of them some are worse than
others it's a more crazy transformers
are [ __ ] day's time and like take a
dollar to
[Music]